so where you from Oh Brazil s verdad
hablo espanol ow
hello everyone welcome to the Lang
focused Channel my name is Paul today
I'm going to talk about Portuguese
Portuguese is a language that far too
often gets ignored in Canada if you tell
someone you want to study Portuguese
they might say oh isn't that kind of
like Spanish or worse yet they might say
why Portuguese why don't you study
Spanish instead and I'm sure Portuguese
speakers just love that the truth is
that Portuguese is one of the world's
major languages with between 215 and 220
million people it is the second most
widely spoken Romance language after
Spanish like Spanish it is so widely
spoken because it spread to the four
corners of the globe during the colonial
period it is the only official language
in Portugal Brazil Mozambique Angola
Cape Verde guinea-bissau South Tomei and
príncipe and it's co official in East
Timor Equatorial Guinea and Macau like
all Romance languages Portuguese
developed from vulgar latin which was
the spoken latin used during the roman
empire together with Castilian Spanish
along with Galician and a few other
languages it forms the Ibero
Romance branch of the Romance language
family it's called Ibero Romance because
it's located on the Iberian Peninsula
when the Romans conquered the Iberian
Peninsula vulgar latin began to be
spoken there and it started to diverge
gradually over time into different
regional dialects and by the 10th
century those dialects had diverged
enough to be considered separate
languages but Portuguese didn't exactly
exist yet galician-portuguese also known
as old Portuguese existed
galician-portuguese diverged into two
separate modern languages Galician and
Portuguese by about the 16th century
although they're still quite similar
from what I hear the language received
its name Portuguese in the year 1290
when the King of Portugal opened the
first University in Portugal and he
decided that the language of instruction
would not be Latin but would be the
vulgar latin the spoken language and he
decided to call that language Portuguese
Portugal was still a relatively new
Kingdom at that time and the language
had never been called Portuguese yet it
was just called vulgar latin and it was
not yet very distinct from the vulgar
latin spoken in galicia in
1500s when the newly developed printing
press helped make Portuguese a
standardized language Portugal had
already started exploring and colonizing
different areas of the world bringing
their language with them the net result
is this Portuguese is spoken by around
10 million people in Portugal but it is
much more dispersed around the world it
is spoken by 205 million people in
Brazil and then of course there is
Africa in Angola it is the native
language of about 5 million people 20%
of the population but it's also widely
used as a lingua franca that unites the
countries different ethnic groups that
is about 15 million more second language
speakers Cape Verde's 500,000 people
speak a portuguese-based creole as their
native language but they learn
Portuguese as a second language for
official purposes also in Guinea Bissau
the most common language is a Portuguese
Creole but Portuguese is also an
official language with around 200,000
native speakers in Mozambique there are
1.9 million native speakers and another
10 million who speak it as a second
language in South Tomei and príncipe it
is spoken by another hundred and twenty
thousand people as a native language in
Equatorial Guinea it was made an
official language in recent years though
nobody really speaks it I think they did
that to promote their relations with
other Portuguese speaking countries in
the area and let's not forget Asia
Portuguese is a co official language in
East Timor which was a Portuguese colony
until 1975 nowadays it is a co official
language again but mostly only older
people can speak it and they are almost
all second language speakers also in
Macau Portuguese is spoken by 0.6% of
the population as a native language and
it's also spoken by some elderly people
as a second language but not so much
these days there are also the former
Portuguese colonies in India
specifically go up Daman and Diu
Portuguese are spoken by some people
there but the numbers are quite small
these days there are also Portuguese
Creoles spoken in Malacca Malaysia
Flores Indonesia batik aloha Sri Lanka
and Aruba if we include the second
language speakers then there are about
250 to 260 million speakers of
Portuguese that does not include the
Creole languages Portuguese is the sixth
most widely spoken language in the world
and it is also the most widely spoken
language in South America even though
it's only spoken in one
t-there brazil there are different
accents and dialects of Portuguese but
the main two categories are European
Portuguese which is spoken in Portugal
and Brazilian Portuguese which is spoken
in Brazil Brazilian Portuguese is
similar to 18th century Portuguese and
also has some influences from the Indian
languages and African languages of the
people who were present in Brazil I've
read a lot of comments by lots of
different people about this but it seems
like the difference between Brazilian
and European Portuguese is basically
like the difference between UK English
versus American English there is a
different accent different pronunciation
there are some different vocabulary
words and idioms and some of the grammar
is slightly different but basically they
are the same language and are
intelligible though sometimes depending
on your exposure to the other variety of
the language you might have some trouble
understanding or communicating which one
is better to study well most students of
Portuguese seem to say that Brazilian
Portuguese is easier to learn and on top
of that Brazil has a huge population of
over 200 million people and you're much
more likely to meet Brazilians around
the world than you are Portuguese people
in my experience on top of that
Brazilian soap operas are very popular
around the world and they make people in
all Portuguese speaking countries quite
familiar with Brazilian Portuguese so in
my opinion the best one to learn is
Brazilian Portuguese unless you have a
specific plan to visit or live in
Portugal there might be some other
reasons I prefer Brazilian Portuguese
but there's no need to get into that
right now did you know the Iberian
Peninsula was under Islamic rule for
several hundred years and during that
time Portugal absorbed some influence
from the Arabic language and that
includes about 800 vocabulary words of
Arabic origin something similar happened
to Spanish too there are also some
Portuguese words that have made their
way into the English vocabulary for
example breeze cashew cobra embarrass
flamingo some food like marmalade
molasses tapioca and the insect mosquito
like most Romance languages Portuguese
has a lot of vocabulary that is
recognizable to English speakers because
of the French and Latin influence on
English let's look at a Portuguese
sentence and I'll show you what I mean
okay
forgive my pronunciation here guys
Taylor Swift au McCann taura composite
ora instrument ista Pro - Torah musica
not Americana so let's look at some of
the words here canto de well that looks
like the English word Kent or which is
someone who recites music in a synagogue
or Church I think so I think that can
Torah is a singer compose a Torah
well that looks like composer so I think
that means musical composer instrument
Teesta well I think that looks like
instrumentalist or musician and pro to
Torah that looks like producer so
prodota musica must mean musical
producer and then a trace that must mean
actress and not the MIDI kana that looks
like North American so if you look at
all of those words and just kind of
analyze each word you can figure out the
meaning of that sentence pretty easily
a lot of Portuguese sentences are like
that though they're not always that
simple but I give you a simple example
just to show you that you can often
recognize words like that so you can
probably learn to read some Portuguese
fairly easily if you're an English
speaker and if you know another Romance
language then you can probably already
read a lot of it without having studied
the language of course learning to speak
it and to write it will require focus
and effort because that means you have
to actually produce the phonology and
produce the grammar as you have to with
any language so stop thinking of
Portuguese as the strange little brother
of Spanish it's actually an important
global language that stands on its own
thank you for watching the Lang focus
channel if you are interested in
Portuguese and in Brazil make sure you
also check out my video on Brazil on my
other channel Gio focus and it's right
here thank you for watching and have a
nice day